hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and what if i told
you that we already know the true
identity of the mysterious m also known
as imusama the one who sits on the empty
throne and controls the entire world
government from the shadows what if i
told you that roger's greatest rival and
one of the most notorious pirates in the
history of the world wasn't actually
defeated at god valley as we've all been
led to believe what if he secretly
accomplished his goal of becoming the
king of the world and for the past 38
years everything has been going
according to his master plan the rise of
blackbeard the failure of the world
government to capture the nika fruit the
real reason why shanks met with the
gorosei what if it's all connected and
what if it all goes back to one man
rocks the
zebec you guys know how this works if
you enjoy our one piece content you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now it really
helps us with that youtube algorithm and
of course if you want to support the
channel directly for free don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications
finally this video will contain one
piece manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned now if
you guys have been watching this channel
for a while then you know that i love to
imagine imusama as a hot yandere waifu
and i mean that is still my preferred
theory but after reading some of your
comments on my previous one piece videos
i was inspired by a bunch of them to
create a theory which states that imu
sama's true identity is none other than
the infamous rox d zebic although zebek
allegedly died 38 years ago he continues
to be relevant in the present time and
in fact the recently released road to
laugh tale booklets emphasized the
importance of rocks road to laughtale
implies that rox's will and design could
still be threatening the world even in
the present time and the booklets also
hint at a deeper connection between
blackbeard and zebek after seeing this
and after seeing your comments i had to
make this video and i had to at least
consider the possibility that everything
we think we know about zebek is a lie
rox d zebic was a notorious and
legendary pirate who is considered to be
roger's single greatest rival and who
was a major scourge on the world of one
piece some four decades before the
present time rox is of course a member
of the d-clan and his ultimate goal was
apparently to become the undisputed king
of the world unlike the heroic pirates
that we know and love pirates like roger
and luffy who dream of becoming the
pirate king and the freest men on the
seas rox seems to have been more
interested in power wealth and control
as such his tactics were often far more
cruel and diabolical than anything that
we would expect from pirates like roger
or luffy it is believed that zebek
formed his pirate crew the rox pirates
44 years ago on the island of hachinosu
this means that the rock's pirates had
at least six years to terrorize the
world of one piece before they were
eventually disbanded after the god
valley incident which took place 38
years ago the rock's pirates included
some of the most powerful and legendary
pirates of the past century including a
young whitebeard big mom and kaido along
with shiki captain john silver axe and
ochoku aka wang ji the last two were
confirmed to have been members in volume
three of the road to laugh tale after
forming his op crew zebek seemed
particularly interested in discovering
the secret history of the world he was
always hunting for forbidden knowledge
about the void century and he openly
declared war on the world government
because he wanted to become the king of
the world we don't know much about what
zebek and the rox pirates did leading up
to the god valley incident but we do
know that zebek was apparently quite
ruthless and willing to do whatever it
takes to get his way this means that he
didn't shy away from even the most
brutal acts such as murder and in fact
he was apparently willing to kill even
the celestial dragons which is the
single gravest crime in the world of one
piece we can't forget that in the one
piece world hurting even a single
celestial dragon could be used as
justification to instantly destroy an
entire kingdom and yet zebek was
apparently willing to threaten the lives
of multiple celestial dragons without a
second thought okay so now that we've
covered everything we know about rox d
zebek prior to the god valley incident
let's briefly talk about eem aka imusama
another character that we know almost
nothing about
imusama is a mysterious being that was
first introduced in chapter 906 of the
manga so more than 20 years after the
manga started publishing and yet imu
sama immediately shocked all fans of one
piece as it was revealed that this being
is the true ruler of the world
government the one who sits on the empty
throne and the one to whom even the
gorosei must bow down to nobody besides
the very upper echelon of the world
government is even aware of imusama's
existence and yet this being is the one
who really decides what the world
government does and doesn't do and who
or what will be erased from history in
short imusama is the de facto king of
the world the very title that zebek had
set out to attain four decades ago
little is known about imusama's
personality other than the fact that
this person enjoys casual strolls
through the garden and playing with
butterflies we also know that this being
has taken a special interest in four
individuals luffy blackbeard vivi and
shirahoshi imusama is also in possession
of a giant straw hat that has been
locked away inside a massive freezing
vault in marijua and imusama is also
implied to have used a saber which is a
specific type of sword in order to
pierce through a photo of shirahoshi
this is interesting because a number of
very important characters have been
shown to use sabers in the story
including shanks roger and of course
zebek in fact as we know blackbeard
named his ship the saber of zebek
imusama's use of a saber could just be a
coincidence this could be yet another
important character who just happens to
use a saber but we can't rule out the
possibility that this is a subtle hint
about imusama's true identity and a
secret connection between blackbeard and
zebek and this brings us to that
notorious god valley incident which is
the linchpin of this entire theory
everything depends on what actually
happened at god valley and what really
happened to rox d zebic after the epic
battle that saw the rox pirates taking
on roger and his crew plus garp and the
marines at the same time we know that 38
years ago zebek and his overpowered crew
attacked the mysterious island known as
god valley and according to sengoku
multiple celestial dragons were present
on god valley at the time of the attack
we don't know exactly how many celestial
dragons were there we don't know who
they were and we don't know why they
were on the island but judging by the
nature of the incident itself and by the
great lengths that the world government
went through to hide everything that
happened there we can assume that the
celestial dragons present were extremely
important to the world government for
all we know these celestial dragons who
were at god valley may have even been
the gorosei themselves protecting these
particular celestial dragons and their
slaves from zebek was apparently so
crucial for the world government that
they were willing to do something
unprecedented they actually teamed up
with goldie roger a notorious pirate who
was under normal circumstances a sworn
enemy of the world government and so
garp and roger led the fight against the
rock's pirates and according to the
official story as it was told to us by
sengoku roger and garp won the battle
zebek was apparently killed the rock's
pirates were disbanded and it was during
this battle that garp earned his
legendary title the hero of the marines
now unfortunately the details of the big
battle are extremely scarce all we know
is that at some point big mom seems to
have saved kaido's life by giving him
the mythical zone devil fruit that he
became known for later the truth about
the entire incident was strictly
censored by the world government and the
island of god valley itself is said to
have vanished from the face of the earth
we don't know how exactly it vanished
but now it is gone and it cannot even be
found on a map we can assume that the
vanishing was not the result of a
traditional buster call because sengoku
doesn't say that it was blown apart or
destroyed by weapons he says that the
island disappeared
entirely and he also implies that zebek
is no longer among the living now most
of us have always assumed that sengoku's
account was correct and that zebek died
at god valley but how do we know for
sure that it is true i mean sengoku's
description of the incident is
deliberately vague and he implies that
if he says too much he could be putting
everyone who hears the information in
grave danger so he may be withholding
crucial information deliberately or
perhaps the world government withheld
crucial information even from him after
all the insane lengths they went through
to erase the god valley incident from
history means that they wouldn't think
twice about deceiving even their own top
officers is it possible that everything
that we thought we knew about god valley
is wrong what if zebic didn't actually
lose the big battle at god valley what
if he actually succeeded in his mission
to become the undisputed king of the
world
maybe zebek attacked god valley because
he knew that there was something special
there maybe even something related to
the national treasure of marijuana an
item first mentioned by doflamingo in
chapter
761 although he doesn't explain the
nature of the treasure doffy does state
that this national treasure could be
used to rule over the entire world
perhaps zebic obtained this very
treasure at god valley and with it he
was able to force the gorosei to
acknowledge him as the secret ruler of
the world he then faked his death and
censored as much information about god
valley as possible in order to hide the
fact that the entire world was now under
his control after all you don't have to
fear your enemies if your enemies think
that you're already dead and you don't
have to worry about someone overthrowing
you if no one even knows that you are
the one in charge this would honestly be
the ultimate machiavellian move
a move worthy of someone that blackbeard
himself clearly looks up to according to
this zebek is emu theory the real reason
why the rock's pirates were disbanded
after god valley wasn't because zebek
died it was because zebek didn't need
them anymore because he already achieved
his ultimate goal the rocks pirates were
never about loyalty anyway they were
just a collection of powerful
individuals using each other to further
their own goals and so once zebek
achieved his goal he simply disbanded
his crew possibly making them all think
that he died at god valley so what if
the pirate that shanks wanted to talk to
the gorosei about was neither luffy nor
blackbeard but zebek himself perhaps
shanks knows imusama's true identity and
he might know it because roger revealed
it to him before his death if this zebek
emu theory is true
then were roger and garp also tricked
into thinking that zebek died at god
valley or did they know that there was
more to the story for that matter is
zebek as evil as we've been led to
believe or are things maybe a bit more
complicated than that for example could
zebek actually be working to destroy the
world government from within
in order to further his own plans and so
that is why the gorosei were so
ineffective in capturing luffy and the
nika devil fruit it is because imu aka
zebek intentionally kept them focused on
other things and i mean when we consider
just how obnoxious and unpopular the
celestial dragons are in general it is
almost as if the entire system wants to
create enemies for itself by directly
pushing people to rebel against it maybe
this was all by design unbeknownst to
the world government their ruler
imusamam is actually undermining them
from within what if imusama aka zebik
preserved that giant straw hat in
marijua because he's actually awaiting
joyboy's return if that were the case if
zebeck's ultimate goal was more
complicated than just an evil guy
wanting power then maybe garp and roger
were in on it all along maybe these
three powerful members of the d-clan
made a pact to destroy the world
government by infiltrating it and taking
it down from within if so then zebic
garp and roger were essentially the
previous generations luffy ace and sabo
we just don't realize it yet
and maybe roger revealed this pact to
shanks before he died which is why
shanks appears to know more than
everyone else
this idea that roger garp and zebek
formed a secret pact to create a new
world from the shadows is an intriguing
one but it's just as possible that imu
aka zebek really is a ruthless
machiavellian overlord who will turn out
to be the final villain of the story and
his connection to blackbeard may
resemble something like the connection
between madara and obito for those of
you who are familiar with naruto and of
course all of these scenarios that i
mentioned only make sense if we actually
accept that imusama really is zebic
which would be insane if true but at
this point it is just speculation
although if it turns out to be true then
i totally want the credit and because
this is just speculation for fun i wanna
know what do you guys think what is
imusama's true identity and could he
actually be rox d zebek himself
what is the national treasure of marijua
and how is it possible that this one
item can apparently be used to rule the
world finally will imusama turn out to
be the final villain in one piece
don't forget to share your thoughts down
in the comments below if you guys
enjoyed this crazy theory video and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment it only takes you
a second but it helps me out with that
youtube algorithm and if you haven't
subscribed already do me a big favor and
click that subscribe button and also
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications it is a completely free
but very real way of directly supporting
the channel you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys